don't you think that people should learn
more after they graduate school than
during school like throughout the rest
of their life okay so you're gonna get
me started let's get this thing hold me
back hold me back so think about it just
think about the what's actually
happening what graduation day let's go
back to high school right you know there
were people if not yourself on the last
day of school
well sorry last day in the spring last
day you know before summer the people
say school's out for summer and the
School's Out forever great rock songs I
don't know if that's where you're going
with school's out for the summer people
cheer School's Out forever they cheer
even more and we have a a rock so what's
that Alice Cooper yeah yeah okay so so
and people you can picture this tossing
their notes in the air as they descend
done with learning okay and then I think
to myself oh my gosh yeah
we have failed
as Educators to instill a sense of
Eternal curiosity within you so that you
become a lifelong learner you will spend
many more years of your life not in
school than in and if you're glad you're
out of school then your knowledge of the
world your wisdom your insights have
ossified in that moment and that then
becomes
your Forever perspective on decisions
you make in life yet the world keeps
changing and so so the failure the
educational system is you think and you
believe and you feel that learning is a
chore
rather than a delight
and that's got to change otherwise what
what kind of world are we making for us
you know there was a story about two
different uh uh athletes I think it was
Federer and tight tiger how they became
the greatest of all time in their space
where tiger was methodical with a
disciplinarian mom and dad and was kind
of intentional at two years old this
guy's gonna learn how to golf and
Military all this stuff and then Federer
was kind of like he fell in love with
the game himself it just kind of like in
organic yes and it was two different one
enjoyed it more than the other the way
where Federer actually enjoyed the
journey when tiger created a lot of
unnecessary pressures it's like being an
auto die deck which is like something
you want to do yourself yeah so I I
would also yes in addition to that
consider that what is the ceremony of
graduation called it's called what
graduation no but the thing the event is
commencement oh commencement speech
correct yeah commencement commencement
speech all right so commence means to
begin
it doesn't mean to end the beginning of
your journey I would say the beginning
of of your journey
being a lifelong learner and that's what
I try to instill in people as adults if
I'm with you I want to celebrate
learning new stuff with you every moment
we're together Neil when when I think
about I'm sorry when I think about
you're not sorry you want to knock them
out of there we brought them in when we
realized there's more than an hour but
okay when when uh when I think about
teachers in my life that impacted my
life right like that you know Miss uh uh
Sinclair before you tell me about her I
will tell you about her and I've never
met you or her before today I think so
yes are you ready go for it
um you loved her class not because
she gave good exams or because the
homework was enlightening you loved your
class because she was passionate about
the subject she was teaching am I right
or wrong no question about it she was a
major in the Army so I joined the army
okay uh and you know yesterday I'm
having a conversation one of our guys at
my house
by the way she was 4 10. she was 4 10.
no joke she was 410. still today were
pen pals huh she was health and guidance
okay yeah so till today I went back and
surprised her now we're friends every
time she dates somebody she introduced
them to me and I'm I'm playing a
different role in our life today than I
did before but it's more family very
very different kind of a relationship
none of the you know just a very good
relationship together but question
question for you is how much of a person
being good in a subject has to do with
interest that the individual has versus
the teacher that has a way of teaching
that you know gets interest gets
excitement like when I listen to you
talk I get excited because you're
excited about out a topic right how much
of it has to do I'm interested in math
how much has to do most mad teachers
suck
do you know what I'm saying
I hate math but this question is you're
such a math guy that could any of
teacher inspired you to to learn more
about math right so so I have several
ways to approach that please so I
tweeted once that was needlessly
controversial I think people didn't
pause and think deeply enough about what
I posted because I I put way more
thought into a tweet than most people
put into their reaction to it and so
that creates a a sometimes ships are
sailing in the night my comment was
students who get straight A's
do so not because of good teachers but
in spite of Bad Teachers
and
what that means is
if you get straight A's that meant you
got straight A's even when you had bad
teachers
that's what Straight A's means so the
quality of the teacher was irrelevant to
your performance
so you're an independent learner yeah at
that point then there are people who get
bad grades everywhere
so good teachers didn't make any
difference to them so they're bad
students but for most people a good
teacher enables them to do better and a
bad teacher they don't do as well that's
for most people and so so all I'm saying
is
we need good teachers and Bad Teachers
there should be a way to filter them out
fire them no really though because the
ten years are you with the 10-year
system we all know who the bad teachers
are sure everybody why do we keep them
though because we need a way to make
that measurement and it's hard it's
difficult without worrying about some
kind of bias I would say two years later
students assess who their worst teacher
was that way their grade is not
dependent yeah and they're out and they
don't you know they're not they got
nothing invested anymore in it and then
let that sit on their record that
that'll filter teachers immediately I
think great teachers are I think great
teachers are underpaid uh uh I think
average teachers are getting paid what
they're getting paid and I think bad
teachers need to be filtered out and get
fired unfortunately the system doesn't
allow for it right now right right so
that has to be that would need to be
modified first of all but second getting
back to your point yeah yes I think
they're people who are who are
self-driven and if they do what they
love they will probably be better at
that than anything else that they might
be told to do can I give you a
perspective and you challenge me I love
okay no I don't if it's if it's
objectively verifiable I won't challenge
you so you so you know like I one time I
asked how to grow in my office uh uh you
know with uh one of our guys his wife is
sitting there and she's like look I'm
not a big fan of rich people I'm like
okay tell me why and we're having this
guy I said did you like math in school
she says no I can't stand math so I
started asking Democrats and Republicans
both questions are you a math person are
you a science person are you an uh PE
are you more what are you and one of the
things I notice is a lot of guys on the
right were math people a lot of the guys
on the left were more science more
journalism more creative more art is
where they were at so do you think a
part of like what you're saying is there
are those are going to get good grades
no matter who the teacher is dardos are
going to get bad grades no matter who
the teachers and then there are those in
the middle like an independent that's
open to being in you know persuaded to
get better in math or science if the
teacher's a good teacher
right so what's the question the
question is does somebody are there
those that no matter if you give them a
great teacher or a bad teacher they're
going to get bad grades and no matter if
you give them a good teacher about
they're going to get great grades okay I
have another response today please and
another controversial tweet which really
shouldn't have been all right the Tweet
was
how often do we hear teachers say
the students just don't want to learn
when that teacher should really be
saying I suck at my job
as an educator it is my duty to figure
out what key works in your ability to
learn and if I don't am I going to run
run around and blame you or gonna say to
myself I was too lazy to put in the
extra effort to figure it out so I
operate on the principle that if I'm not
succeeding in the first few moments of
my encounter with you it's my duty and
obligation as an educator to figure out
what you care about so that I can teach
you things in a way that matters to you
and that you can continue in life
continuing powerful you can continue in
life with a level of curiosity that by
the way as children we're all curious
as adults it's been beaten out of us or
it's a flame has has dimmed and so what
I want to do is fan those Embers
reignite them in your adulthood
so that you can have this childhood
curiosity about things you don't know
that we all once had how much of of that
analogy or is essentially the scientific
method that you're applying to to
teachers meaning like hey you're going
through the science uh project all right
cool didn't work let's keep going again
let's keep trying again I have a
hypothesis let's figure it out and but
it sounds very similar it's never unlike
what many people think it's never
really about the answer
because at some point you want to learn
to love the questions themselves damn
because the questions are the seeds of
curiosity
questions are I wonder and I don't know
so parents who have kids I don't know if
you guys have kids if you have kids you
can say mommy daddy what's this what's
that or Mommy Mommy what's this what's
that right whatever is the modern
blended family and so
the parent then gets the answer or
doesn't have the answer they find it
okay
maybe your reply should be
I don't know let's figure it out
and it's the figuring out of the answer
that's
within what a scientist does who said
the stain with problems longer is that
an Einstein quote somebody said genius
is staying with the problems longer uh
uh where you're not giving up right
before it gets hard somebody's sustained
with problems yeah I don't know who that
might have been but that um all with it
I'm all in on that so so Neil so this is
your work you know what else genius is
just seeing what everyone else has seen
but thinking what no one else has
thought
seen what everyone has seen but thinking
what nobody else has thought that's
correct and so those thought pathways
are empowered by your life experience
how many different ways have you seen
problems or moments or incidences or
people places things so that now we all
see the same thing but I will make a
connection that maybe you don't because
I have the capacity to make these
connections within my mind and so that's
very important so I I'm a big uh
promoter of just a person's total life
experience for you to draw upon for
every next thought you might have so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]